this next story from the new york post
misery index shows democrats face
mid-term rout as voters rage at biden i
think the issue of schools is going to
have is obviously having a huge impact
on this not just the misery index but
basically for those aren't familiar the
misery index is looking at inflation
unemployment gas prices and it is so bad
look at this misery index this the
unemployment spike plus the inflation
spike
it is just bad news across the board for
regular people this typically indicates
it's going to be a major party switch
like the congress is going to flip
people are just saying we're done with
this
i think on top of this you have what we
saw in virginia with yunkan parents have
become a voting block which is hilarious
and the democrats keep attacking them
the end result is going to be
well
it's hopeful based on all of the data
we've seen democrats are going to get
purged from congress and the senate joe
biden still in the presidency so it's
not like there's going to be a lot of
movement
and then if the republicans can make
their argument properly 2024 comes
around you get a republican president
and then all of this stuff gets gets
shoved through donald trump one of the
big reasons that i said this august 2020
i was going to be voting for him was
because school choice
was was was on his second term agenda
and what i was saying to people is
you've got pushback on the critical race
theory in government contracting we
can't have that
but school choice makes the most sense
there's no argument against it it should
be a left-wing position
when you when when i you know so i'm
previously mentioning calling school
choice universal school access
because the idea is
families can choose where to send their
their kids they will get a confirmed
right now a poor family can't go go to a
private school but with the school
choice program basically they can now
that's
but you know that's not what they want
right want you in these propaganda
indoctrination centers where they can
control what they what you learn as a
student and they can just
crush the joy out of learning absolutely
the crazy thing though is school choice
is a it should be a left-wing position
i mean if you if you pull the
constituents on the ground polling
consistently shows super majority
support for example the latest real
clear opinion research pulling from 2022
finding that 72 percent of americans
support school choice funding the
following the child to public and
private schools that work best for your
kid but there was also super majority
support among republicans democrats and
independents it only comes to the
elected officials in the state houses
where you see republicans being much
more likely to vote to support school
choice than democrats and that's all
because of the political power dynamics
of the teachers unions we were speaking
a little bit earlier that randy
weingarten's union who had this poll
backfire on them showing republicans up
on education but the american federation
of teachers the second largest teachers
union in the u.s
in 2022 99.997
of their campaign contributions have
gone to democrats
so the democrats are in a catch-22
situation right now and this is why this
is such a good opportunity a golden
opportunity for the gop to become become
the parents party because if they talk
about education the democrats are going
to have to respond in one way or the
other if they come out against parental
rights like we saw with terry mcauliffe
well that's a disaster with the new
special interest group which is parents
but if they come out for parental rights
well then randy weingarten the unions
are going to get mad
ian do you mind talking about what
you're mentioning before the show with
your family yeah which which one exactly
you're watching the show mm-hmm
you're talking about yeah 100 yeah so uh
before the show ian was mentioning that
um
his you were talking to your parents
about biden's brain yeah yeah last time
i went to ohio about a month ago we were
talking about biden and i was like
it goes it changes from time to time but
i was like you know he's losing his mind
and my mom's like i mean he's no he's
not that bad you know or he's no he's
fine and uh and i was just like
in shock but i left i didn't you know
i'm not getting emotional about this
stuff so i went back a couple days ago
and she was like i was like you know the
problem with biden is he's losing his
mind she's like yeah he is and the media
is talking about it now and that's
probably why she started acknowledging
it yeah as soon as you see jimmy kimmel
talk about it and everyone laughs then
it's okay to acknowledge it this is this
is a really great example i was like i
was i i was saying ian i was like tell
them that we on this show have been
showing examples of this for for years
the the true not a shop at a pressure
and so
they need to
look it's not about watching this show
it's about watching shows in this area
where maybe it's because we're younger
and more attuned to what's going on
we we see these things we know what's
happening but when they sit and they
watch corporate press they're they're
not realizing it they're way far behind
everyone else the reason i bring this up
is this is why democrats retain power
because regular people aren't
you know i shouldn't say regular people
but the older generation is not getting
real information they are getting fake
news from the corporate propagandists i
mean weren't they saying that people who
were questioning uh biden's cognitive
abilities were making fun of like a
stuttering issue that he had wasn't that
that was one of their first defense
tactics
i've never seen someone with a
stuttering problem put a medal on
someone's neck backwards and walk off
stage the wrong direction that's not
stuttering well to be fair it is a
common symptom of stuttering when you
reach out to shake invisible hands
when you say words that aren't real
everybody knows when you have a stutter
you don't just stut stutter you also
make words up like like batacaf care and
next now rescind and trinidad a shop out
of pressure you actually only put your
son on on boards of oil companies
getting too close to small children
the doctor's like oh yeah we talked
about that a lot too it's the way he
handles kids on stage the way that he
smells he's not actually sniffing the
hair it's just and women's just so
disturbed another simple sarah reed i
brought up tara reed we talked about
that for a while i mean the binder reit
allegation against biden is damning i'm
just imagining there's like a little boy
and he's stuttering and the doctor is
like we couldn't help but you have all
of the symptoms of a stutter
you're repeating the first syllable of
the word over and over again and your
son has been placed on the energy on the
board of an energy company in ukraine
i've been doing that since i was nine
man oh no
most common symptom you know i'm going
to push back on on school choice a
little bit because i'm wrong
absolutely
because i love it but i need to know i
need to steal man this thing let's go so
what happens when
a bunch of people likes keep one decide
to keep the money they're like okay i'm
gonna i'm gonna homeschool my kid the
mom decides i'm gonna keep the eight
grand a year but then she just doesn't
teach the kid and that's already
happening in the government schools you
want to get rid of all government
schools because some of them don't teach
anything yeah i mean this is using an
outline but but let's let's more
directly respond to this i'll make one
point real quick
when i went to school i had teachers who
didn't teach us anything and it was it
was punishment it was a prison so it's
ungovernable do you think it's
ungovernable no we have uh just like a
health savings account where you can
only use the funding for health services
it's an education it's like an ebt card
for education so you can't go and buy
you know
uh big screen tvs if you do you'll be in
trouble for fraud even even if you did i
think that'd be a better use of the
funds than throwing him to an endless
money pit into the government side
guidance counselors i got to tell you
i think many kids would be better off
not in these schools yeah and not being
educated at all because some of these
schools are doing worse than nothing oh
yeah so the other question is how do you
what do you do in a situation where the
the surrounding schools all send their
kids to the middle this one really good
school and then they all lose money and
start to go out of business or have to
fire teachers and you've got these like
derelict schools that are having i mean
that's the argument that let me i just
want to jump in like imagine there was a
bakery that sold turd rolls
and nobody wanted them but the
government was forcing by taking your
tax money and then funding the turd roll
bakery and then one day someone comes
along and says people should get a
choice on what they eat for breakfast
and they shouldn't have to send their
kids to the third roll bakery
if the turd roll bakery collapses and
all the bakers get fired i'm sorry dude
people just don't eat crap yeah so the
problem is it's not a good argument to
trap the kids in there like the thing
about a business is that they can fail
when they do bad
the bad thing about business is that
they can become exploitative when they
grow large and cumbersome like you know
starbucks for instance when they start
shoving out or i shouldn't single them
out any major fast food can shove out
local mom and pop shops there's a
problem when they grow too large
but
we can address the problem of monopolies
we also need to address the problem of
unf you know uh unfallible government
institution perceivably like well the
school if it's not doing well give it
more money it's like no no no no no and
you've got to recognize that there is no
utopian school solution
because human beings are imperfect
fallible creatures so we can't make any
system perfect but we can remove
government monopolies
and government incentives for corruption
and coercive school policies what do you
think about curriculum
one more on that point um the reality is
school choice is a rising tide that
lifts all boats competition leads to
improvements in every sector of society
including in k-12 education and there
are 28 studies that exist on the topic
25 of the 28 studies find statistically
significant positive effects of private
school choice competition on the
outcomes in the public schools so they
upped their game in response to
competition like you see everywhere else
and at the end of the day if um
the people who make this argument this
is going to destroy the public schools
they don't have much confidence in the
public schools that's not a good
argument to trap kids in there it's a
good argument to let them leave yeah
destroy away please yeah like let the
bad businesses fail are they considered
businesses schools i mean they are with
higher education they are with pre-k why
is it why isn't any different for k-12
education we have a market for schools
already the private sector already
exists in k-12 it's not just that when
when people are looking to buy houses
they check the school districts
specifically because they're shopping
around for good school districts and you
you will find areas with bad schools
people that we shouldn't move there
because they're school so that kind of
thing already exists the issue is my
view of school choice is like you've got
a poor family living in this area and
the school kind of sucks they can't
afford to move they can't afford to jump
to a wealthy area but they can say we
can take this this universal school
access and send our kid to a better
school and give them a better life and
you can save taxpayer money at the same
time they spend fifteen sixteen thousand
dollars in the government schools you
can structure the program to be ten
thousand dollars per kid or twelve
thousand dollars per kid so you can have
a taxpayer savings you could even give
some of that money back to the public
schools they end up with higher
per-pupil funding um and you can create
a win-win situation oh interesting so
you could give a small percentage to
schools where there are no kids going
just to keep that's a really good idea
see there we go thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you